so a little while ago members of my
family had three bits of minor surgery
about a half-hour each and we got three
sets of bills for the first one the
anesthesia bill alone was $2,000 the
second one $2,000
the third one $6,000 so I'm a journalist
I'm like what's up with that I found out
that I was actually for the expensive
one being charged 1419 dollars for a
generic anti-nausea drug that I could
buy online for $2.49
I had a long and unsatisfactory argument
with the hospital the insurer and my
employer everybody agreed that this was
totally fine but he got me thinking the
more I talked to people the more I
realized nobody has any idea what stuff
costs in health care not before during
or after that procedure attest do you
have any idea what it's going to cost
it's only months later that you get an
explanation of benefits that explains
exactly nothing so this came back to me
a little while later I volunteered for a
buyout from the New York Times I'd
worked for more than 20 years as a
journalist I was looking for my next act
it turned out that next act was to build
a company telling people what stuff
costs in health care I went a shark tank
type pitch contest to do just that
health costs ate up almost 18% of our
gross domestic product last year but
nobody has any idea what stuff costs but
what if we did know so we started out
small
we called doctors and hospitals and
asked them what they would accept as a
cash payment for simple procedures some
people were helpful a lot of people hung
up on us
some people were just plain rude they
said we don't know or our lawyers won't
let us tell you that but we did get a
lot of information we found for example
that here in the New York area you could
get an echo
cardiogram for $200 in Brooklyn or for
$2,150 in Manhattan just a few miles
away New Orleans the same simple blood
test nineteen dollars over here
five hundred twenty two dollars just a
few blocks away San Francisco the same
MRI four hundred seventy five dollars or
six thousand two hundred twenty one
dollars just twenty five miles away
these pricing variations existed for all
the procedures and all the cities that
we surveyed then we started to ask
people to tell us their health bills in
partnership with public radio station
WNYC here in New York we asked women
that tell us the prices of their
mammograms people told us nobody would
do that that it was too personal but in
the space of three weeks four hundred
women told us about their prices then we
started to make it easier for people to
share their data into our online
searchable database it's sort of like a
mash-up of kayak.com
and the ways traffic app for healthcare
we call it a community created guide to
health costs our survey and
crowdsourcing work grew into
partnerships with top newsrooms
nationwide in New Orleans Philadelphia
San Francisco Los Angeles Miami and
other places we use the data to tell
stories about people who are suffering
and how to avoid that suffering to avoid
that gotcha bill a woman in New Orleans
saved nearly four thousand dollars using
our data a San Francisco contributors
saved nearly thirteen hundred dollars by
putting away his insurance card and
paying cash there are a lot of people
who are going to in network hospitals
and getting out of network bills and
then there was the hospital that
continued to bill a dead man we learned
that thousands of people wanted to tell
us their prices they want to learn what
stuff costs find out how to argue a bill
help us solve this problem that's
hurting them and their friends and
families we talked to people who had to
sell a car to pay a health bill go into
bankruptcy skip a treatment because of
the costs imagine if you could afford
the diagnosis but not the cure
we set up a huge conversation about
costs involving doctors and hospitals
yes but also their patients or as we
like to call them people we changed
policy a consumer protection bill that
had been stalled in the Louisiana
Legislature for ten years passed after
we launched let's face it this huge
slow-rolling public health crisis is a
national emergency and I don't think
government's going to help us out
anytime soon but what if the answer was
really simple make all the prices public
all the time what our individual bills
go down our health premiums be really
clear about this this is a United States
problem in most of the rest of the
developed world sick people don't have
to worry about money it's also true that
price transparency will not solve every
problem there will still be expensive
treatments huge friction from our
insurance system there will still be
fraud and a massive problem with over
treatment and over diagnosis and not
everything is shoppable not everybody
wants the cheapest appendectomy or the
cheapest cancer care but when we talk
about these clear facts we're looking at
a real issue that's actually very simple
when we first started calling for prices
we actually felt like we were going to
be arrested it seemed kind of
transgressive to talk about medicine and
health care in the same breath and yet
it became liberating because we found
not only data but also a good and honest
people out there in the system who want
to help folks get the care they need at
a price they can afford
and it got easier to ask so I'll leave
you with some questions what if we all
knew what stuff costs in health care in
advance what if every time you googled
for an MRI
you got dropdowns telling you where to
buy and for how much the way you do when
you google for a laser printer what if
all of the time and energy and money
that spent hiding prices was squeezed
out of the system what if each one of us
could pick the $19 test every time
instead of the
$522 one what our individual bills go
down our premiums I don't know but if
you don't ask you'll never know and you
might save a ton of money and I've got
to think that a lot of us and the system
itself would be a lot healthier thank
you
[Applause]